[MUSIC]
Wait, do you want to say my
name is David Aaker or no?
>> I guess I could do that.
>> Yeah, that'd be fine.
Okay, go for it.
>> Okay, I'm David Aaker, and
I'm really looking forward to
joining you Wednesday night.
I'm going to start out the event by
telling you some things about Jennifer.
Some of those things was surprise you and
then I'm show you an amazing story.
And I'm going to talk about why that
story so amazing, so effective.
And how organizations use stories like
that to communicate us to teaching
message.
>> Also be talking about
signature stories.
But in a context of
individuals not organizations.
So what we wanted you to do is actually
share some questions you might have for
either of us, right?
So what kind of questions might you like?
>> Yeah, I think there's some questions
about how signature stories used in your
organization.
Or how the problems you might have in
getting signature stories into the mix.
And Jennifer probably be interested in
signature stories as it applies to your
own personal life.
>> Which might be more
interesting in some ways.
We invite you actually to submit six
word stories to us before the session.
In fact we might even have an award for
the best six word story that you submit.
>> The dragonfly affect.
>> It may or may not be a book.
[LAUGH] So please give us some
questions before the event.
Or share your own six word stories
about your organizations or yourself.
>> And I just wanted to say both
Jennifer and I have a lot of ties,
and a lot of affection for
both us and Stanford.
And so we're delighted to be in company
of people that also have ties and
affection for Stanford and Burkley.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Go Bears and Cardinal.
>> Go Cardinal.
>> Is there such
a-
>> And Bears.
>> Is there such an expression,
go Cardinal?
>> Tree, go tree.
>> Go tree.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Welcome to all of you to
this wonderful event bringing us together.
This is our 15th annual Berkeley Hoss
celebration here at the GAP headquarters.
We're really honored to
be part of the vision.
Most of you know or
many of you knew Don Fisher.
His vision not just for
this company but also at Berkeley Hoss.
And for society more generally
it's just a perfect venue for
us to showcase Berkeley Hoss and
also to showcase Stanford GSB.
So welcome also to all of our
colleagues and friends at Stanford GSB.
And for those of you that are here from
Stanford please look around the room,
see how much red is being worn.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Is this even by Berkeley people.
>> So
this is a very special night for you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> This year we spotlight the research as
you know.
And insights of a father,
daughter marketing pair that have
just been remarkable contributors
to both of these institutions.
Berkeley Haas' Professor
emeritus David Aaker and
his daughter at
Standford GSB Jennifer Aaker.
David and Jennifer will discuss
the importance of signature stories.
What are our signature stories?
I mean I hope all of us will leave
the room thinking a little bit more about
what our signature stories are?
I certainly when I thought about this
topic had to think about that and
we'll talk more about that.
How do we create them,
how do we keep them alive?
Where does their emotional
impact come from?
And how do they serve us?
How do they help us move the world in the
direction that we hope to move the world?
As you'll see here from the program slide,
on this you'll hear from both of them.
And we'll get a chance to use some of the
questions that you've submitted already
to hear from them on questions as well.
So I'm going to introduce David the vice
chairman of Profit Brand Strategy and
as I mentioned Professor Emeritus
at Berkeley Haas.
David is the recipient of four career
awards for contributions to the practice
and science of marketing most recently
being the Nyama Marketing Hall of Fame.
He's published over 100 articles,
he's published over 17 books.
He has sold over 1
million copies of books.
Some of the popular ones
that many of you studied,
some of you when you were at Berkley.
Strategic market management,
building strong brands, brand relevance.
His latest book Aaker on Branding and
this one pretty much sums
up a lot of the others.
So if you're going to get
one get the latest one.
It's been helpful to me, it really is,
as a non marketing person just
a very quick story if I may.
My office when I cam back I
was an undergrad from Berkley,
I got to come back to Berkley in 1993 as a
faculty member that was a dream come true.
And in 1993 we were still in Barrows and
so they said that's your office.
And the guy next to me was David Aaker,
and
I got to know David Aaker
as my office mate.
And we became quite good friends and
I got to meet Jennifer I remember
in that Barrows office together.
So I have a connection with David and
I think he helped me to think about
the importance of marketing
which is not where I come from.
So he is recognized authority
obviously on brand strategy and
really just a worldwide
expert in this area.
Please join me in welcoming
our own David Aaker.
Thank you David.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thanks Rich.
Well thanks for coming,
I want to start out by giving you
an example of a signature story.
And as you watch this video think to
yourself, is this to me intriguing?
Does this feel authentic?
Is this involving?
Does it draw me in?
So can you play the video?
[MUSIC]
>> Wahh, wush wush.
[FOREIGN]
[MUSIC]
Is not incredible?
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I'm
going to make four observations
about this signature story.
First of all, it's really powerful.
It is intriguing.
Don't you wonder what Atari was doing?
Being so obsessed with the tree,
and taking care of the tree?
And then we get kind of a surprise.
We find out that that tree she marked,
when she knew she was
going to have a baby.
And that tree has been
the symbol of the babies growth.
And now the baby reached five.
And isn't it authentic?
We get to know Atari.
We get to know her father.
We even see the village they're living in.
It is nothing, but real.
It has to be authentic to us.
And third it's involving, isn't it?
You get drawn in, you get emotionally
involved in the whole story.
And you really care, so it's powerful.
Second thing is that
it communicates facts.
Now, we know from all kinds of research
that if you put facts out there.
A list of four, or five,
or six, seven facts.
Like 2 million children die
before the age of five.
And the delight life
program that involves all kinds of things
in the school and out of the school.
And that will affect these,
you put a bunch of facts out there.
People don't attend to them,
they don't notice them.
Their brain kind of says, you know
here's three or four or five facts.
Should I process them?
I'll probably forget them.
They probably won't have any use for me.
Don't just ignore them.
Facts get ignored.
And the worst thing is even if they get
processed, even if people for one reason,
or another process these facts,
they don't persuade.
And there's several reasons for that, but
one of them is you have counter arguing.
When you see facts in the natural
inclination is to say,
this guy is trying to persuade me,
what is he not telling me?
Maybe 5 million children,
how does he know it's 5 million children?
Where does he get the data?
And how do you know that this washing
hands is going to affect that, and
how much it will affect that, and
maybe it'll just have a tiny effect.
It's counter-arguing.
So, now, think, inter-story.
So, instead of printing the facts,
we tell a story.
And what we can do is we can
slip the facts in to the story.
So, when you hear the story you come to
know that there is a problem with infant
mortality.
And it's related to hand-washing.
And so, they slip that in,
but even more important,
they set you up, so, now,
the facts are relevant.
So, now, you're willing to process facts.
And you remember them,
because they're attached to the story.
So, we have some facts that
are kind of within the story, but
then we have some facts at the end.
And the story motivates you
to process those facts.
The third thing is,
that this video is incredibly successful.
11 million people watched this video.
And it cost nothing for
Lifebuoy to put it out there.
11 million people watched it.
And not only that, but
there was two companion videos.
One of them had a girl named
Shaka that was seven years old.
And she represented a unborn baby
projected forward seven years.
So, she was sort of not a ghost, but
a projection commenting on her seven
years that hadn't occurred yet.
But will occur.
And she was talking to her mother, and
she talked about how she sang lullabies,
how she read stories, and
how she washed her hands.
And the girl was so
grateful that her mother had done that.
That got 14 million views.
The three of them together
got 44 million views.
And that doesnt count all of
the sort of press results,
or press accounts of this whole program,
and
these signature stories
within this program.
And it also created a nice feeling,
you watch this video and
you feel good, don't you?
You feel good about the program help
a child reach five, you feel good about
Life Boy, there's some people that
would even feel good about Unilever.
But most people don't know
Life Boy is made by Unilever.
Unilever, incidentally, is the company
I admire more than any other,
because of their philosophy of business.
It's quite remarkable.
But that feeling in the video
gets transferred to the brand.
And we know that's to again,
hundreds of research studies.
We know if you like an ad, you're going
to like the brand that did the ad.
It gets transferred.
We know that.
And it was successful in helping this
program help a child reach five,
because Life Boy is one half
of their goal of getting a billion people
to change their hand washing habits.
They're halfway there after eight years,
and this video helped them get there.
Fourth thing I wanted to say is
that this is a signature story.
And a signature story is intriguing,
gets attention.
It is authentic, and
that means that words like phony,
selling, this is just a selling job, they
don't enter your mind if it's authentic.
It's involving,
that means you get drawn in and
that's one of the most powerful
characteristics of any story.
And it's a narrative, that means it's sort
of once upon a time this happened and
then that happened, and
it's not a set of facts.
And it takes as a strategic message.
In this case the strategic
message is about
explaining the infant mortality rate.
The fact that the hand washing can
prevent that and there's a program.
It's help a child reach five.
And it's done by Life Boy.
And I should say also it's
a strategic story for this program,
Help a Child Reach Five.
It's a strategic story for
Life Boy, the brand Life Boy.
And in some cases, for some people,
it's a signature story for Unilever.
If you look at the Unilever.
Any report you'll see
a reference to this story.
So, why do we use signature
stories as perferms.
Let me give you two reasons.
First of all, again,
there's study after study after study,
probably 500 studies,
that demonstrate vividly
that if you compare facts to a story,
it has the same general content.
A story will get more attention.
It will be, it will persuade.
It will change perceptions.
It will be remembered.
And it will be passed on.
Much more than facts.
And these, we're not talking
about a little bit of improve,
we're talking about orders of magnitude,
two times, five times, ten times.
And the second reason we're
using signature stories,
come back to the digital
world we're living in.
Marketers struggle how do we
cope with the digital world?
Things are different.
My take on digital,
is that content is king.
And content means stories.
So, company after company are learning
that it's good to actually hire
journalists, have a little department and
create and manage stories.
So let me now,
turn to introducing Jennifer.
I have to say,
that I had mixed feelings about
having such an accomplished daughter.
>> [LAUGH]
>> On one hand, I get some reflected glory
Because people think I had
something to do with that.
[LAUGH]
>> Which is not true, but
it doesn't affect the fact I
still get reflected glory.
But there's some issues, first of all,
people call me up regularly.
I mean, honest to God they call me up and
say, Jennifer's busy,
would you like to speak on?
[LAUGH]
>> And
I used to be the primary speaker,
now I'm just kind of the warmup act.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And just literally two weeks ago,
my friend and colleague Scott Davis,
was at a conference call with me.
And he said,
Dave I gotta tell you a story.
My son Ben is in the business
school in Indiana,
and I said to him I know it's coming now,
I hear this all the time.
His Professor is using my book, or
his Professor is said something
about one of my ideas.
He said, his professor played
a five minute video on humor from
Jennifer Aaker, and it was terrific, and
isn't that the daughter of your friend?
>> [LAUGH]
>> And then,
in the same conversation,
Same conversation,
Scott said, well your new book on,
I'm writing a book on strategic stories.
That's going to be my next book.
I expanded an article Jennifer and I did
for California Management into a book.
And he said,
you gotta call it Aaker Strategic Stories.
Because you got Aaker on brand in,
Aaker strategies, Aaker on you can
have a whole bunch of books and
it would be a series, and
I thought that was a really great idea.
But then I thought most
people are going to think
Jennifer finally wrote a second book.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
my wife suggested why don't you call
it Dee Aaker on Strategic Stories?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I
tell you working with Jennifer
is not a walk in the park.
She is very opinionated.
And we have these vigorous conversations
about issues we disagree on and
they always end one of three ways.
She will send after fights
she'll get exhausted.
And she'll say,
dad you gotta stop being repetitive.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Or
she will say, dad you gotta
work on your listening skills.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But the worst is,
I'll be in a situation where I'll tee up,
Some, crystallized.
Three reasons why her
position is just flat wrong.
And anybody could see that.
And just as I get into that,
she'll say, gotta go, love you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I'm talking to dead air.
Now she's a really amazing person,
she's literally opened
the five research areas for
her field like brand personality,
cross culture, research and
humor and meaningfulness and
she's just a wonderful person,
she's the most caring empathetic person
I know, and she's my best friend.
>> Aw.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you!
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Go ahead and
>> After my mom, Jan and Jolyn,
after the three of you,
then I'm his best friend.
I'm just saying that, so, thank you dad.
It's totally true that my favorite way
to end a conversation with my dad is,
"Gotta go, I love you.", and so
I am really honored to be here today.
There are so many people int
he room that I recognize and
I really wanted to say thank
you not just to my dad,
who I think we all, can we al just say
like who does not love Dave Aaker.
[Clapping].
It's so funny like,
I saw a few of you before,
and you are talking about
how great Dave is and
I'm like yeah I've got to go, ok.
So you are so beloved and
have had such an impact its amazing,
I also wanted to thank my sister Jan, and
Jolyn, Rich and Brian for being here.
Our family means everything to us.
And so one of the incredible
honors of living here and
being here tonight is
really you guys being here.
Where's my Mom?
All right.
And our heart and soul of the family.
It's so nice to be here.
Anyway, I already saw Dad
looking at his watch so.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I wanted to start off this with
the first [LAUGH] quote that I could,
because I didn't have time to prep today,
I've been busy working hours.
Dad's been thinking about this talk,
I just got out of class at 5:30,
rushed over here.
This morning, I'm like I'm going
to put together some thoughts.
He's like what are you going to do?
And he goes the worse case scenario,
the worst thing you can do is go along.
And then he don't go too long.
That's all I ask, so and then he said
what are you going to talk about?
So I said well,
I was thinking about talking about how do
you create personal signature stories?
You're going to talk
about company stories.
I'm going to talk about
personal signature stories.
I think that's really interesting.
And he goes hm.
[LAUGH]
>> And
it was pretty much nothing after that.
And if you know Dad, there's one of three
ways that he responds after the silence.
because he is incapable of
maintaining the silence.
Have you?
No, not going to happen.
So what are the three ways
that guy responds after he,
cannot stop, but
actually have to say something.
The first thing is.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And it's actually heard as?
Okay, and what that means is I
totally disagree with you but
I'm not going to say it out loud,
because then you will hang up on me.
So that's what it means.
The second thing is, okay,
and it's heard as oookay.
And what that means is,
I totally disagree with you but
I really don't want you to hang up on me.
But I really disagree with you.
And the third thing you'll say is, no.
And what it sounds like is, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
That's basically, it's a two year old,
no, you've got it all wrong.
And so that's basically
what I heard this morning.
>> [LAUGH]
>> All three of them.
Wait a minute, and then he said,
I go, well [LAUGH] and
then he offers suggestions.
And he goes, what you really
should talk about is purpose,
like you're killing it with
this whole purpose thing.
And I go well I think I might talk about
how do you cultivate signature stories.
He goes no, no, no, no, no.
And so,
what I'm going to talk about today is,
how do you create personal
signature stories?
And we have 50 slides, so just buckle in.
We're just going to get very comfortable.
So how do you create
personal signature stories?
The first is carve out clear
areas of incompetence.
By the way, these were all completely
inspired by our family and
my father in particular.
Be sneaky, seek highs and
lows, and bank your stories.
It's fine if they are brief and pithy.
So that's what I'm going
to talk about today.
The first thing is carve out
clear areas of incompetence.
I think it's fair to say, Tommy, that
dad has done an extraordinarily good job
of carving out these clear
areas of incompetence.
Earlier days, he never took a picture.
I don't think he's ever
actually taken a picture.
This is my mom taking a picture
of me being held by my dad.
He's very good at holding people,
he's good at picking clothing.
He's not great at actually
taking a picture.
Very clear in social settings,
not good at that.
He's also not great at elegant eating.
So if you are at a dinner party and
you might have a muffin over here,
very good chance he might
have a nibble of it.
And also maybe like have some
disastrous unintended consequences.
Now this sounds like I'm making fun
of dad, I'm not making fun of dad.
He is a genius.
My husband, Andy Smith, is he here?
All right.
>> [LAUGH]
>> My husband, Andy Smith,
is also a genius.
I find a lot of men in my life
are geniuses in this way.
So carving out clear areas in competence,
if I could just share a quick story.
So Andy, when we got married early on,
I decided wasn't going to be that 70 year
old Grandma who took out the garbage.
I really wanted my husband to do that.
And you know in the first week of
marriage, whoever takes out the garbage
first is basically going to take out
the garbage for the rest of their life.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I knew that, I'm no dummy.
Got dad as my dad.
And so I said,
would you take out the garbage?
And he said yeah, absolutely I would.
So when it didn't go out I thought
that was curious but I wasn't worried.
I said, hm, probably used words
to describe what I wanted.
I'll put a calendar request
on his calendar and
he will accept it and then it will go out.
So when it didn't go out,
I thought that was weird.
So I updated the task request
on his Google Calendar.
And I said garbage goes out, happy face,
happy face, exclamation point,
exclamation point in case he was
conditioned as a young child to think
that garbage going out
is a negative thing.
I was going to classically condition
him to believe it was a positive thing.
And so he accepted that update and
it didn't go out.
And so I said what's going on,
why is the garbage not going out?
I don't know how to be more clear.
And he goes I would like
to take out the garbage but
I'm very confused,
what time does it go out?
Does it go out on the right
hand side of the driveway or
the left hand side of the driveway?
And after they pick it up,
when do I take it in or?
I had take out the garbage.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Our kids take out the garbage.
Other people take out the garbage now.
But it's beautiful.
Carving out clear areas of confidence
not only gives you stories but
it also reduces the amount of time
you actually have to do work.
So what I had done, by the way, once I
learned these techniques from other people
is I decided to actually carve
out incompetence around cooking.
So not only do I not cook, the few
times I do cook and I burn myself, I
take a picture and post it on social media
so that people can be clear, I don't cook.
This is what happens when I cook.
All right the second,
be sneaky and then brand things.
In one study, we asked individuals
what's your happiest childhood memory?
We asked parents.
We asked kids.
And these are the types of answers
that were revealed in the study.
Constructing Leaf Forests with my brother,
our Family Read day the day after
Christmas, fishing for tadpoles with Jane
in the summer, dancing to
Michael Jackson's Beat It with my friends,
our Linda Evangelista Spring Cleaning
Fashion Shows, and Special Days,
I said, actually, Special Days.
So, let me tell you what special days are.
Special days are when dad took Jan or
Joe or I when we were young,
and basically,
we were on a need to know basis.
So, where are we going to go?
He wasn't going to tell us.
And so, but
he would want to do certain things.
Like he'd want to go to the Cal game but
we wouldn't want to go,
so he'd call it a special day.
Wouldn't tell us where
we were going to go,
we're just going to go on a special day.
And we were so excited.
My God, it's a special day.
And then we would arrive at Cal Berkeley
and we'd have pompoms, get them there and
cotton candy at the time and stuff.
And it actually ended up being
ridiculously memorable, a fantastic story.
And actually I'm here right
now talking about it.
And so
he was sneaky in very systematic ways and
then he would brand them as special days.
I mean it is genius, right?
He probably took us on five.
Mom, who did way more stuff with this,
and mom, just no offense,
did not brand those things as special days
and now we remember the special days.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Third, seek highs and lows.
So when you think of personal signature
stories, you're really not thinking of
I was winning, winning, winning, winning,
winning, won, got the promotion, whatever,
you're really thinking about highs and
lows.
These are the opportunities for
stories, right?
So when dad says intriguing,
authentic, involving.
Involving a big piece of that is feeling
like you're going on a high and a low, and
so you're designing these roller coasters.
And that makes sense,
because when we see movies,
like James Bond,
they all have highs and lows.
The arc here is wow, what happened?
I don't know, he gets the girl.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
every single James Bond film has that arc.
Or Jurassic Park, what's going on?
T-Rex.
What's going on?
Big T-Rex.
Big, big T-Rex.
So arcs don't have to be sophisticated,
they just have to have some highs and
lows.
Or Casablanca, which has these,
sort of, micro story themes in it.
And so when you are finding
signature stories for yourself,
or your family, or your life,
you're looking for those highs and lows,
which is a really exciting way to
actually raise kids for example.
because when the lows hit,
you know it's goinna be a great story.
And if you can have a comedic lens
That allows them to take risks and
you don't take things so seriously.
It also allows you to document things.
So I wanted to mention that Disneyland is,
as I think we can all agree,
the worst place ever.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Very, very unhappy place.
But most people don't remember that
because they don't take pictures of
the unhappy moments.
We do.
We do and
we also write it up in our holiday card.
I'll share one from a few years back.
Cooper, one of our sons,
wrote a highlight of the year: Disneyland.
We prepared for the trip for weeks,
filling our jean pockets with cookies for
sustenance and
brushing up on our Disneyland history.
On arrival though,
we found that the parking was painful,
tickets expensive, lines long.
On the upside, my dad found
an iPhone app with a GPS driven map,
ranked attraction checklist, and
crowdsourced wait-time guide
to get us around the park strategically,
optimizing our fun while minimizing lines.
Unfortunately the iPhone
died in 30 minutes.
Necessity forced us to try
something arguably better.
A cleverly, color coded conveniently
foldable pocket size tool.
It's called a map.
It's provided by Disneyland.
It's amazingly free.
The only free thing at Disneyland.
[LAUGH] So that was fortuitous.
On the way out, we met Sandra (our
au pair) and Tea Sloane (our sister)
outside the Haunted House,
where Sandra was shaking from heatstroke.
Being a "doctor," my mom
recommended she eat some grapes.
[LAUGH] Seconds later, Sandra's body
decided to put the grapes in reverse.
[LAUGH] We left with Sandra to find
a place with less bad advice and
fewer bystanders.
She slept the entire car ride home, and
we were required to be silent for
the whole time.
So it ended up on an upnote.
We can't wait to go back.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So now the question is,
why would you seek highs and lows?
I know Disneyland's awful.
Why would I go with my family, besides,
they're my family and you should go?
What's actually experienced is,
you get there to Disneyland, and
then you get in lines and
you don't realize how long they are.
And then you get to Small World which its
branded The Happiest Place On Earth, true?
I'm not sure.
But then you take a picture
of Devon literally crying,
which I always find hilarious.
And then they're tired.
Cooper and Devon are twins,
are on Andy's lap, fatigued.
But then you get the fireworks,
and then you forget the cotton
candy all over their face.
And Tea's is a mess, and
our au pair's throwing up.
But you just remember the end, right?
You remember the peak, and
you remember the end, and
that has disproportionate impact.
So, if we seek highs and
lows, and if we design for
memories rather than just experience,
we'll cultivate a life of story.
And last, bank your stories,
even if they're short and pithy.
We talk a lot about sort
of six word stories, and
I find this to be a really powerful tool.
Larry Smith and others have actually
generalized this concept, but
it was really born by Hemingway
who once wrote baby shoes.
For sale.
Never Worn.
So I made my students in the Power of
Story class write six-word stories to
describe their lives, and
you all shared stories.
So, and
we're going to share a few of these.
Stories that you,
I'll just like have you look at them.
See if we can have a little
vote on which one's best.
Dad, which one did you say you liked?
There was a few that you really liked.
>> I like the MBA theater.
>> The MBA theater.
>> Get lucky once, twice.
>> Get lucky once, twice?
>> Yeah, and ambition with purpose.
>> Yeah, Robert Chatwani who's here but
had a huge impact.
Just huge impact on my life for
the two years I was at Haas.
He led to The Drive and Fly Effect,
was a book that Andy and
I wrote together with Carly Adler.
I also liked,
married the wrong girl, fixed it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But the best was Kay Aaker's, so Kay,
you get the award for best six word story.
We got here, thank you Rich.
And for the others,
we're going to have three runners up,
which we will tell you about later,
and you will get some books.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Branding.
These six word stories
are really important.
You can do them in the day.
You can have your kids do them at night.
Instead of having a conversation about
what you did today over the dinner table,
you could have a conversation
about what story was unlocked.
And how many of you have soulless
conversations at the dinner table about
what did you do today?
And then,
what are you going to do tomorrow?
Like that was one thing.
You were always, Dad, so
averse to us talking about logistics.
But that was defines our life.
It's to-do lists oftentimes.
It's logistics.
It's goals that we think
are really important.
But what actually defines
our lives are the stories.
And if you think of.
Your wedding if you had one, or
potentially someday you might die,
and the memorial you might have.
What are the stories that are shared?
It's not a set of lists, it's not
a set of things that you accomplished.
It's the stories that
others remember about you.
So bank the stories,
even if it's six words or less.
And bank those stories that are distinct,
that make you or
your family truly distinct.
Bold, and so you take risks that
are relevant to different audiences.
Dad talked a lot about authenticity and
truth.
We're living in a time right now where
there's a significant trust deficit.
We don't trust necessarily
our politicians.
We don't trust oftentimes leaders.
And it's not just the finance industry.
It's everywhere.
But what people trust is people they know,
people whose story they believe in.
And so cultivating those stories
becomes really, really important and
codifying them and capturing them.
Does as well.
These bold stories, these memorable
stories so that they stick over time.
Stories that are sharable so
that they can spread and garner action,
and stories that depict something larger,
something meaningful.
So I just wanted to end with
one of my favorite quotes.
Tell me the true facts and I'll learn,
tell me the truth and I'll believe.
But tell me a story and
it will live in my heart forever.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> By the way, there's oops!
We have some questions, alright,
should I sit here
>> Why don't you sit here and David,
if you would come up as well.
You submitted questions and
thank you for that in advance,
I'll just kick this off but I know,
I think you have some other questions.
The first question which I think
is a little bit personal but
I'll start with it, I know a lot of
you had this on your mind Jennifer and
David would you tell us
your signature stories,
please, each of you.
Thank you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You want me to start?
>> Yeah.
>> Well in I was teaching strategy at
Berkeley, and
I had written a book on strategy
>> And
I came to realize that people were
too focused on short-term profits.
Enduring by the stock market and others,
not to blame the Rich for that but...
>> [LAUGH]
>> He was one of them.
>> He was part of the evil empire.
Gee I'm tempted to tell.
When I was side by side with him I
used to go over and say, you know
if I spent so much time with students I
could win the best teacher award too.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But anyway.
[LAUGH]
>> So I said, how can I do this,
how can I influence this?
And I decided I wanted to spend the rest
of my career teaching people to manage for
the long term.
Which to me meant to build assets instead
of driving short-term financials.
And so I said,
what kind of assets should I do?
And given my background in market
research and strategy and in advertising.
And also, I realized that brand equity
was starting to become
a topic of conversation.
And I thought it should be brands.
That's where I fit.
And I looked at other kinds
of assets of a firm and
I wasn't very relevant to any of them.
So I decided to help people build brands
as a way to focus on assets
instead of financials.
And so I kind of grandiosely said,
I'm going to try to change the way
people think of marketing and
the way they think of brands and
the way they run their business.
I would be embarrassed to say that then,
but now I'm older, who cares.
So anyway that's how I
started in branding.
I wrote my first book sort
of defining brand equity and
my second book how do
you manage brand equity.
And since then I continue
to write branding books and
be really focused on that basic problem.
How to get people to
think more strategically.
>> That's fantastic, I would say my
equivalent of that one would be,
I never wanted to be in marketing.
So I-
>> So
you're implying you
[INAUDIBLE] in marketing?
>> No, I'm still not, I'm even
less in marketing than I ever was.
But my goal was to always
be a great hopefully.
A great mom,
hopefully a great partner, Andy,
this is where you say like yes, nailed it.
[LAUGH]
And I wanted to be a great friend and
hopefully an athlete and hopefully
[INAUDIBLE] about something in the world.
And wanted to do great in my career,
but I just didn't know what it was.
And I think,
when you talk to executives or
anyone, you found out that a lot
of people have closet careers.
They wanted to be this, but
they didn't know how or whatever.
And so for me that closet
career was to be an oncologist.
My mom's father,
my grandfather died of cancer early age.
She's worked for
hospice now for gosh, 40 years,
meals on wheels with others in the room.
And it just had a personal impact even
though I didn't see it personally.
But I think all of us have
been touched by cancer.
And so
that was what was really important to me.
But I couldn't see my way
to being an oncologist, but
also having these other goals.
To be all of these other things.
And so
I saw my dad be this remarkable dad.
Who was so good with time management and
so fantastic with ideas and science.
And I thought it was so
inspirational, so that's why I
became a behavioral scientist.
But every Sunday,
I would feel a little bit depressed.
I don't know how many of you guys
on Sundays or like one day a week,
you just kind of get depressed.
And ten years of depression,
on Sundays, I saw it coming, it hit it,
it was consistent and I thought,
is it that I have a lack of friends.
What is it?
But it would have something
to do with meaning for me,
I just felt not very connected to
something that was truly meaningful.
So fast forward,
I got recruited back to Stanford.
I was lucky enough to join Berkeley for
two years and thank you for
those of you who took my class and
are here.
You mean a lot to me.
I have a deep deep love for
Berkley and Bears, but
then I went back to Stanford.
But I do have a feeling
of what's right for me.
And when I came back to Stanford,
which felt very right for me.
At the time I had the opportunity
to basically really resonate with
a story that Robert [INAUDIBLE] MBA shared
with me on the last day of my class.
Which is called creativity and innovation.
And in this story he told,
I told about his best friend Sumeir,
many of you guys know this story,
who had leukemia.
And Robert because he's so strategic,
so creative, so confident with attitude.
He was able to come up with a framework,
a way of thinking about harnessing
story and social media.
To get over 25,000 on the Bone Marrow
Registry in order to find a perfect match
for Samir and he did that, and it was
just such a mesmerizing story for me.
That Andy and I,
I went back that night and
actually shared with him the story and
we ended up writing a book based on it.
I never wanted to write a book.
That was dad's thing.
But it literally felt compelled to me,
and I could go on,
on about the reverberating
effects of that signature story.
But even though I never
became an oncologist,
I felt donating a year of my life to try
and get more people on the bone marrow
registry and
still now really feeling connected.
That very meaningful thing A,
I no longer have empty Sundays.
I feel very full on Sundays, and B, we
have this book which is why you wrote so
many of your books that it creates legacy.
It creates meaning, and so that's one
of my signature stories and I have so
many more too.
But hopefully you'll all be thinking
of in every domain of your life,
one signature story that
really defines you.
And if you haven't yet,
please do so tonight.
It would make us incredibly happy
just even writing it down with
six words or less.
Just a title and
then sharing it with your loved ones.
That would be a big successful night.
All right, so I'm going to jump in and
ask a couple questions.
All right, so let's see, how do you create
a powerful personal story when
you're working in an ordinary job?
I don't know if Marissa's here, but
Marissa asked that question that I loved.
So I'm going to ask it to you.
>> I don't think this is how it works,
we both answer these questions but anyway.
>> Well, I will,
if I have something interesting to say.
>> Anyway, well I think that if
you're in a position in an organization
to create a higher purpose.
Or to maybe activate a higher
purpose that is in the organization
by creating a program or something,
then you should do that.
I think that it just provides
meanings in the lives of employees.
And it provides respect for the people
do business with your organization.
But if you're not in a position to
do that, you might consider having
another life, another professional life as
a volunteer perhaps with an organization
that does have a higher purpose
that you really admire.
>> I totally disagree.
I'm just kidding.
I think that was a great answer.
I see why you put that first,
because you wanted to talk about purpose.
Basically, you were going to fit that in.
>> I was just trying to help you
out because purpose is kind of your
thing now, isn't it?
Yeah [LAUGH].
>> [LAUGH]
>> After carving out clear
areas of incompetence,
it will be my thing.
It's true,
I teach a class with Emily Ma at Google X,
and it is called rethinking purpose.
The other thing I would add to that
answer is that a lot of times, in fact
there is data by Gallop and others, that
show that at least in the United States.
Over 50% of the people
working at their institutions
don't understand the purpose
of their institution or
their mission and
of those that do, 80% don't care.
I mean, it's just huge data sets and
it's a starkly depressing trend.
So what happens if you're
at this ordinary job and
there's no sort of higher purpose there?
One interesting thing about
the purpose research is that
purpose oftentimes is thought as this
like purpose with a big capital P but
it actually is a lower case p oftentimes.
So everyone thinks it’s sort of this
destination, this inspired mission I
wanted to be out on colleges, make
a dent in cancer but more often than not
purpose is designed much more from
this lower case p perspective.
It’s what you're doing in the day to day.
Are you learning?
Do you feel like you're
accessing some unique strengths?
Are you passionate about
what you're doing?
And do you feel like what you're
doing is what the world needs?
And those are the elements
that get you into flow.
That and whether you really like.
The people you are working with at least
have one best friend at your organization.
So if you can just kind of get
into that sort of lowercase
key mentality that will
often write you out.
Okay, I'm going to have another question.
What advice do you have for
individuals in organizations faced
with a rival who generates powerful
stories that are patently untrue.
Steve's question.
>> Well, I'm a great believer
that the best story wins and
the last heard story wins.
So you've gotta really
change the conversation.
I think you need to create
your own signature story, and
make that more prominent
than this one that is,
if you look at Walmart for example.
There was a time when 90% of
the world wouldn't shop at
Walmart because they were so
disgusted with a lot of their policies.
And then Walmart, created this alternative
conversation they sort of went green.
They got religion about
environmental things.
They're doing enormous stuff on that.
They're working with a community and
they've really provided at least
an alternate conversation.
At least when you talk about Walmart,
you don't have to talk about how
they treat their employees and
how they buy from China and
how they treat their suppliers and so on.
There's an option.
So I think you have to create
a competitive, strategic story or
signature story that wins the day
against the one that's false.
>> Totally disagree, I'm just kidding.
Another way to think about it is listening
better to what that story is and
the language that's being used by
that competitor, that audience and
I've been thinking a lot
about this right now,
it feels like we're living in
a relatively decisive world.
One of the many reasons we're so
happy to be here today is not just
because of our deep love for Rich and
also what Haas has been
able to I think create for
you and also for
us more generally, but also.
This ability to bridge Stanford and
Berkeley, it's a very sort of small
divisive, kind of funny,
competitive environment but
it's still very gratifying to be able
to make these sort of small dents.
When you're in divisive environments where
there's it's not clear what's truth and
what's not, when there's different
people in organizations and groups
that have alternative narratives, that
are very stuck in their head all of us.
What I find to be interesting and
useful, and
it's backed by a significant
amount of social science as well.
Is understanding and feeling empathy for
individuals who have a very different
narrative, even if it's patently false.
And understanding the language that
they're using, where they're coming
from and so before you potentially
design a counternarrative.
And so understanding, having empathy and
understanding language and
then aligning where there are some
common thread feels to be,
to me, quite inspiring and hopeful.
>> Do we have time for
another question Arch?
>> Okay.
I'm [LAUGH] just going to All
right going with James Tinsley.
How have signature stories
changed in recent years?
Are we telling the same stories
through different media or
are we telling fundamentally
different stories?
I can go if you don't.
>> You go ahead.
>> Okay [LAUGH].
I thought this was such
an interesting question and
the reason is because we're living
in such a trust deficit and
that stories and people that you trust
is so important, authenticity is at
such a premium and I know its an overused,
kind of trendy word in many regards.
But there's something important about
stories that not only are authentic but
they feel authentic and
I think that is really a significant
trend that's happening.
It's not really a qualitative
different type of story per se but
it has implications, it's always going
to be pretty, pretty, pretty most
marketing or manufactured goods or
it is going to be some highs and lows?
Look at the story that dad shared,
it wasn't like happy happy happy happy,
right.
There were some highs and there was lows.
Second shift is that I think
people need to design for
partners more, that you need to
feel like you're a part of a story.
So it's not just like,
I'm going to share with you a story and
you're going to receive it.
But if you feel part of the story.
This is what Dragonfly and
Robert story was all about.
If you feel part of it,
then you'll get people aligned.
And if you get people aligned,
and they feel part of the story,
you can actually make action happen.
And I think we're all living in a world
right now where it's very important for
us to be aligned at what is good in
the world, and how we can make action
toward that what we believe in and
how we can make progress happen together.
There is a phrase that I'll just
end with which is people want to be
valued members of a winning
team on an inspired mission.
And you don't have to be
winning all the time.
But have you heard this before?
But you need to have
a pathway toward winning and
I like that sentence because you have to
have clarity and that inspired mission.
You have to have people knowing
what role on the team do they have.
>> I think another really important
thing in the branding world is energy.
And we know that brands
have been declining for
15 years all around the world, the
exception are those brands with energy.
And it's really hard to
get energy into a brand.
And one of the reasons,
a practical reason we
want to higher purpose is because
they will give energy to the brand.
You look at Lifebuoy,
I mean they make a bar of soap.
It is pretty hard to create energy for
a bar of soap, but
helping a child reach five and three
videos that got 44 million exposures?
That's energy.
And it gives life to one of the great
global brands which is Life Court.
Fantastic, we have one last question.
How do you create a six word story or
any signature story?
This is Linda.
>> I have nothing to say about that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, all right.
One thing, I don't know if Linda's here,
but what I would say is you're always
thinking about change or transformation.
So think about your life.
What did it used to be and
what are you now?
So how did you sort of change.
And that usually gets you away
from I am this, I'm going to this,
I'm going to do this, et cetera,
that kind of linear progression.
As you start to figure out
signature stories, baby shoes for
sale number one there's an art to it.
And there's kind of a reveal to it.
And so think of transformation and change.
And I think right now again,
I think all of us really
are in a stronger place
if we're adoptable, or
open to change, and
we're able to transform.
So that would be my one tip.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Please
join me in thanking these two wonderful
friends and scholars of all of us.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE] Thank you both.
You know I think it was maybe a year and
a half ago that I saw Jennifer and
this idea came up, and we thought if
we could only get you two together.
And I'm so
happy we were able to make this happen.
When I was, when I was seven,
my brothers were 14 and 15, and
one of the things I remember so distinctly
is my parents driving us to Half Moon Bay.
We had one of those woody Station Wagons
and we filled it with pumpkins,
it was early October, and we brought
those pumpkins back to our home and
our parents let us sell those pumpkins.
We had a stand in front
of the neighborhood and
we sold those pumpkins and that was
a thrill for me, that was a thrill for me.
And two years later I may
have been about nine and
my brothers were, you know, the end of
high school we graduated to jewelry.
They were in the puka shell business.
>> [LAUGH]
>> High volume, low margin.
I was seven years younger,
I didn't like the business.
I was doing tiger eye, turquoise,
much high quality stuff.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And, but I loved it.
I absolutely loved that I got to
got to Berkley as an undergrad.
And I come form a business family if you
hadn't noticed from those stories and
I wanted to go into business and
I knew it thrilled me.
I was a sophomore and
I'd taken Intermediate Macroeconomics
at Berkeley, and
one of my faculty members, the teacher,
I'd never talked to her one on one.
She come sup to me after
handing back the midterm,
and I I had done pretty
well on the midterm.
And she said, come see me,
please, in my office.
I went to go see her.
Her name was Fran Ban Liu.
And she said, have you ever thought
about getting a PhD in economics?
Neither of my parents
had a four-year degree.
That was not an identity I'd
ever even thought about.
And I walked out of her office
never having thought about that.
Couple weeks later she got me together
with somebody named George Akerlof.
I didn't know who George Akerlof was.
He subsequently won a Nobel Prize, but
she wanted me to sort of talk to somebody
who had done that, and
we can't be what we can't see, so
when people ask me why does this
institution mean so much to you?
You know that's my story.
And I think a lot of us
have a story like that.
Whether your story is connect to
Stanford or Berkley or you know,
these institutions matter and
it's why we're so invested in them.
That's why we come together around them.
And that's part of why
we keep them strong.
And we must keep them strong.
So whichever of those two
institutions you're part of,
keep leaning into them because
they just matter so much.
Thanks for coming out tonight.
Go Bears.
>> [APPLAUSE]
I'd like to thank Rick Splines and
the Halls Alumni Group for
putting this event on and
inviting our friends from Stanford.
And I hope you got a chance to
think about signature stories and
apply them in your organization.
>> Right, so
think about signature stories.
Both at work and in life and even in the
day to day, when you're having your next
dinner meal with your family, I think
about actually sharing a story rather
than necessarily sharing what you did
today or what you're going to do tomorrow.
I'm not saying you have to cook,
I'm just saying.
>> Of course not.
>> Ask people what their story is.
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC]